how are you feeling today I know you
said you've been in the hospital a
couple of days how's everything been
today is day 14 for me with covin 19 the
last four days I've been hospitalized
here at Mountain View with low oxygen in
lung capacity and I've been diagnosed
with double ammonia Cova pneumonia on
both of my lungs today's the first day
that I've felt a little bit stronger and
better because they've been filling me
up with a lot of antibiotics steroids
and blood thinners because they don't
want my blood to clot in a heal finally
like something's happening with the
medicine and it's allowing me to feel
stronger thank God you were admitted
into the hospital three days ago I was
admitted into the hospital in the
morning of 4th July I was at home
monitoring my symptoms and I have an
oxygen reader at home and my oxygen that
day was falling below 90% it was in the
low 80s and I washed it for a good 40
minutes and I finally said to my husband
that I either need to call an ambulance
or I need you to get me to the hospital
because I can't breathe any more on my
own that's very serious and especially
since you're 39 years old on all
accounts you're a young healthy man I
would assume before Kovac started yes I
mean I'm 39 years old living a normal
life my dream career of being a
principal here in the district
I was following social guidelines
washing my hands making sure we were
safe and I woke up one day and my life
changed and it's scary to think that at
39 years old you can't breathe on your
own because of a virus that's taking
over your lungs
and the possibility of not making it and
having those conversations with family
and loved ones 39 is something nobody
should ever have to deal with do you
have any idea where you may have got
encoded to be honest no there was a
stretch of time before I got sick though
we were again wearing masks and being
and being safe so I really no idea where
I picked it up I just know that we did
all of our things were supposed to do
and we still ended up with it me and my
husband both test positive and how's
your husband doing he's much better than
I am Christian his path is a complete
opposite of my path
he had minimal symptoms he lost his
smell and his taste and a bit of a
headache entire but thank God he didn't
go down the route I went and he was able
to take care of me for those first nine
days at home where I walked through hell
pretty much fighting for my life when
you're saying you walk through how what
were those days like up until the point
you said you can't breathe on your own
so my symptoms started with me waking up
and throwing up and I had a very high
fever
I've got 103 and every day it was the
same thing over and over
fever spikes uncontrollable chills
nausea body aches to the point where I
couldn't I'd have four or five blankets
on me and I'm still freezing cold or
then my fever would spike to 103 and I
couldn't eat and I couldn't sleep and
just being in the worst pain you can
imagine people want to say it's like
comparable to the flu but it's the flu
times a hundred 24 hours a day you wake
up and you think what's going to happen
to
what this virus gonna bring to me today
to really test me and it's truly
something no one can prepare for because
it affects all so differently and it's
taken so much out of me and I'm trying
every day to find it
you're a principal within the Clark
County School District the fact you got
kovat there are lots of discussions
right now about how to reopen what the
school year will look like but since you
have that experience I mean what do you
want the school district to know in
regards to this and the precautions that
need to be in place um I really feel
like the school leadership above me my
region supervisors our superintendent
and I really feel like the school board
are really sitting down as a
collaborative team and working hard to
figure out the best solution I love my
job I love my kids that I get to work
with I love my teachers and my support
staff I love my community and I know
everybody's working really hard to find
solutions to bring us back together
safely and I trust in their ability to
make those decisions and just my biggest
thing is I need everyone to realize we
need to work together because it's not
going to be a single person to decide we
have to come together as a community to
keep us safe keep our children safe
our staff safe and we're gonna need a
lot of patience and a lot of flexibility
coming because there's two things that
I'm looking forward to president one is
rolling out of this hospital and
wrapping my arms around my family and
two is seeing my kids back at school of
my teachers back at school and seeing
their smiles and reminding me why I did
this job and I love my job and and and
be there for them
I know right now your focus is on the
recovery aspect your life but you also
mention you love your job students for
you how do you want to try and keep
everyone safe because KO bida is not
going away anytime soon from what we're
seeing especially our numbers are
continuing to go up so how do you want
to make sure when everyone can come back
together that are all safe and no one
has to go through your same experience
just making sure that we're all trained
and the latest CDC guidelines and
ensuring to my school buildings and
forcing those social distancing
guidelines in the classrooms and that we
are having our kids wear those masks and
our children feel safe at school on
earth so you know having our parents
feel safe to send them with school by
limiting the number of kids in our
classrooms and just being really aware
of what's going on around us in the
building and making sure we're cleaning
and sanitizing and keeping our kids safe
and so yeah just following those
proposed protocols and guidelines and
ensuring they're happening in the
building do you think it's not because
even you mentioned you were following
all the guidelines and this still
happened I do I I don't have the right
answers I think I think it will be
enough as long as we're diligent and
people practice these CDC guidelines and
work with their children and it's a
community effort to keep all of us safe
and keep all of our kids safe and keep
all of our teachers safe and support
staff safe so it's not just the efforts
of me and my building it's the efforts
of me and the community right now
how how is it even just talking with me
is a struggle to breathe
it is you know I'm still in my infancy
here at the hospital with my with my
treatment and so you know the breathing
comes and goes but like I said I feel
the medication is helping and I'm hoping
I'm on a road to getting the mone out of
my body and getting getting better
what has been the toughest part so far
through all of this the toughest part is
being 39 and talking about dying with my
husband and what that would look like
how he would move on without me what
life would be what would happen and I
can't imagine I've had to have those
conversations with my loved one being so
young and he can't physically visit you
at the hospital but have you been able
to FaceTime him during your stay yeah no
one's a lot of comments he me and I'm
isolated my own room and left my own
thoughts but thank goodness for FaceTime
in technology it gives me some hope and
some need to look forward to speaking of
hope and what to look forward to
yesterday you did do a facebook life a
lot of love a lot of comments what was
it like sharing your experience and
reading all those messages yesterday was
hard Kristin because the doctor dropped
a lot of me yesterday and it was very
touch-and-go if I was going to go to
this new intensive unit for care and
just just brought a lot of emotions to
the surface because not only am i
fighting for my health but it's also
being here alone it's fighting those
mental demons sometimes to that
treatment when you're alone and you're
you're dealing with this massive virus
and so when I posted yesterday was raw
and real and just me me being the truth
my speaking my truth and what was
happening and my video got so many
comments and the messages are beautiful
they've gotten messages from around the
world actually people reaching out to me
and supporting me and I'm just trying to
tell my story so people realize that
this is in our lives it's in our society
it's happening and it can happen to
anyone
no one's immune to this no one's you
know I guess but it's a big message that
you have been wanting to share because
people hear about kovat but it seems you
don't really understand the impact until
it happens to you someone you love or
someone you know it's just some people
think they're hearing about is that how
your perception was originally before
you got it yes ma'am I felt like there
was an excuse me I felt like there was a
narrative in society in Vegas that it's
safe
Wow you don't have to wear a mask go go
to the casinos and go IDO and it's gonna
be okay
and that kind of narrative that was out
there allowed me to feel a little bit
okay maybe I can go out and not you know
worry so much about the virus and look
what happened to me I turned my life
upside down in an instant and I don't
want anybody else to have to go through
sitting you know in a hospital room by
themselves contemplating if they're
gonna live or die for a night out at the
casino mansion
you know contemplating about whether
you're gonna live or die I know I spoke
with a teacher yesterday she mentioned
that there are educators who are getting
their affairs in order right now their
wills and work because they're nervous
about returning to the classroom do you
think that they're in the right mindset
to get a will at this point in time
before returning to the job just in case
this happens
I think everyone's perception is their
reality and I think their actions are
validated if they feel that way and you
know as a leader as a building leader
I'm part of my job is to support them no
matter how or what they meet and if
that's something they need to get in
order to feel comfortable or to feel
safer or to feel um proactive in the
situation that I support that and I know
I have a lot of teacher friends from my
career that are nervous about going back
to school and we're really just hoping
that our leadership and the school board
work hard to ease those fears that a lot
of people have about coming back to the
school year and really develop a plan
that's gonna work for all of us
to keep us safe and so we'll have to
wait and see I do believe in our
leadership I know their hearts are in
the right place and that's all we can
ask is that these people have their
hearts in the right place for everyone
and I know they do and they're looking
out for us so what is the road to
recovery right now so the doctor is
continuing with the steroids and the
medications and the flushing and
hopefully getting the fluid out of my
body the biggest concern for them
Tristan right now is obviously in the
pneumonia they need to get the pneumonia
out of my lungs so I can breathe and
fingers crossed treatment continues I
know the doctor had mentioned it's about
a ten day approach we have to see what
my body does with what's going in it
there's have been some suggestions from
the doctors about alternative treatments
like using plasma from a recovered kovat
person and another treatment of that's
been around nationally floating is the
runs of your treatment they might do
that as well but right now they're
waiting and seeing
what they've done so far and looking at
x-rays and evaluating as a team here at
Mountain View a wonderful job well I
appreciate you taking the time to speak
with me I don't want to stress your
lungs out too much anymore is there
anything else that you'd like to add or
want to let the public know um I want to
say thank you from the bottom of my
heart to everyone that's reached out to
me and said me messages of encouragement
and have said prayers and raised me in
spirit and cut me a positive energy you
don't know how much it means to me be
here alone in this room to have
thousands and thousands of people in my
corner and I just want everyone to be
safe and realize that it's real and it
can happen and just be very diligent and
everything you do in your life and
realize that it can change in the
heartbeat thank you so much thank you
Kristen